that it's great to be here and great to
see you when I'm very delighted and
honored to have been asked to interview
but and I told him that in in my life he
has become a verb because it's all over
the last few months I've keep saying I'm
people say what are you doing say well
I'm parking you know and I've been
Palmer and panicking I'm panicking so I
don't have to panic what I have to
actually interview or on comics so
that's what I've been doing for the last
few months trying to read as much as I
can and now i feel really immersed and
really really delighted and i think that
the new book if you are a fan this is
the book i'm going to pitch the book
this is the this beautiful book of
collected essays and some that you might
have seen and many that you've never
seen called other colors this to me was
the insight into the heart of Oren Pamuk
because they're so revealing and so
incisive of his own work but also the
work of so many other writers you are
really a good literary critic I don't
know oh yeah yeah I'm telling you you
are you're fabulous very good so I want
to start with I want to start with a
question about the novel because there
is this optimism it's in the novels
themselves but it's also in all the
essays about so many writers that Oren
has written about and also written
introductions for for the Turkish
translations these beautiful beautiful
tributes to other writers and his
insightfulness into their work but um so
I so I have a question for you about the
novel you say that you write so many
essays and you keep journals you publish
excerpts of thought but in your essays
you talk about you love and devotion to
the novel first and foremost and you
talk about the influence of European
novelists on your opinion about Europe
in general and that your love for Europe
and your framing and understanding of
Europe came through the novel through
Thomas Mann and Joy's Dostoevsky and
then this wonderful essay which you will
read when you get the book old cars and
Frankfurt you wrote that malhomme spoke
the truth when
he said everything in the world exists
to be put into a book without doubt the
sort of book best equipped to absorb
everything in the world is the novel
that's an amazing statement and also in
the black book you have this wonderful
phrase the world is a book and in your
really marvelous introduction to
tristram shandy you have great praise
for that novel in the specific and in
the form in general and you talk about
novelists ability to bring paradise into
the present so would you just talk about
the nature of the form of the novel and
why you think it's so capable ok now
that at the beginning you said that and
the vitality of the novel or group so
that were sorta effect that it still
survives that that it's a common clichy
among the journalists that they always
call you and say well we're doing a
magazine it's arts page and the novel is
dead what do you think which is which is
a neighbor truthful neighbor represents
the truth but it's just a journalistic
cliche and most of her family when I was
writing these articles I was a part of
my brain is worried not worried about is
angry about the comments that the
journalists make about the great art of
the novel which I sometimes very in a
bit self irony say that I'm a humble
servant of this great arm now the novel
beginning from mid 18th century begin to
take over all the previous literary
forms and in fact we can even say that
that we are talking about the
globalization of the world the world
impact in so many ways culturally
globalized that we see the world is
first for example our ways of seeing the
world are almost similar all over the
world after post Renaissance perspect
invention of perspective and Italian and
Dutch painting and after photography we
see the world we are globalized in our
ways of seeing and also is similar in
similar manner we are all global
in in our literary literary imagination
in the forms that we use and the
globalization they say i would say
literary globalization of the world had
been completed years ago when even when
there but no one was talking about
globalization with this i imply that the
art of the novel is well and kicking and
so elastic all over the world that
everyone is using it it is now a common
heritage of humanity and then it has it
has what i would call such an intense
elasticity that it can absorb the
national problems it can observe and
represent the National dramas has where
I would say 4mph lack flexibility so
that it can be you can use and impose
your particular understanding of this
naive form into your corner of the world
discuss the national debate whatever it
is and then it will be it will hold the
nation together because it's such a text
that everyone argues for example let me
give you an example that the novel snow
which i wrote my novel which is a
political novel and which I wrote
nervously is not nervous too but I
published nervously thinking that
everyone will be angry yes everyone was
angry but only run everyone was reading
and discussing and talking I think art
of the novel as a form is one of the
great arts that humanity had developed
which has continuously with changes and
survives some forms of art they change
and then they cannot continue with that
change because it's a dead end while art
of the novel you know wait for that for
the last 20 years we are for example
witnessing return to me in 18th century
desire kind of novel that we have lots
of essays and novels combined I for
example consider myself as a sort of a
sort of a representative of the code
encyclopedic novel that you can put
anything into novel and novels are on
Stifler barriers everything malhar maze
words to the effect that everything
is in the end in the world for it for
the imaginary imaginative novelist
imaginative a literary person is in fact
produced made to end up in a book and
that's how I see the world as well
because I'm a novelist and I care about
that I the informative on cinematic
quality of the novel's you in the
beginning of snow you have a wonderful
epigram from Stendahl and you say
politics in a literary work or a pistol
shot in the middle of a concert a crude
affair though one impossible to ignore
we are about to speak of very ugly
matters why do you think there's a
conflict or I why is it so difficult to
create a political novel or where is the
down for them there are so many problems
with the political novel and yeah I
wrote one I wrote on I don't think it is
a great Jean that produces that produced
masterpieces it's a limited Jean and
Dostoyevsky Conrad stand out and some
others produce the most with the best
examples of the Jean but then it's also
troubled by some inner contradictions
maybe I will go into that that the
problem with political novel is that
that most of the time people who had
heartfelt political agendas write it and
once you have such a heartfelt political
agendas and you have heartfelt pulled
the door gentles when there are followed
by political tension in that corner of
the world when there is something
unstable when there is a highly
dramatized political situation than the
novelist or the artist fields interiors
these problems and wants to say
something on the political level and
once he commits himself so much to those
problems then he's not a good novels
because he takes signs he cannot
identify with everyone he has clear-cut
good guys bad guys white guys black
kinds and once he won a person is
morally so much morally committed to the
political scene then it is almost
impossible or it's very problematical to
produce a satisfying convene
singh aesthetically convincing in
beautiful so to speak which is a mia
normal we would but some novelists
managed to do that Dostoyevsky did that
those kids he was when I think the
greatest the political novel ever was is
those days is processed sometimes
translated as the dominance and it's
because of los reyes key while had this
tortoise key and quality in his spirit
that of believing angrily with energy to
social close to getting angry about so
many people he was he had also a nasty
side to his spirit he was angry to
everyone but on the other hand he had
also this thing in his unique that he
also managed even in his anger to
identify with the bad guy and that the
and so he it's hard to be politically
motivated and committed and write a
novel which will not be biased or even
if it's biased it may be it shall be
biased that the characters that the
novelist identify with the bad
characters that is the fragile moment of
the political novel so I always think
that it's not it can never be a major
Zhang but it's a minor John but it has
its classics and I also wrote one such a
fabulous very good what I thought was so
wonderful this notion that a writer a
novelist can break through and it's your
phrase the confines of the self by
entering into the other nosov characters
and it would seem at this moment in time
when other nurse is such a difficult
issue in the world globally that that
that would be a major reason to via
novelist would be to to try to get close
to that which is so different and you I
thought achieved this amazingly in snow
right with your care you're covered with
your character blue who you made so
attractive and sand but what was what
was really interesting to me was not
that not just that you were
able to represent a radical Islamist as
you call him but that you were
philosophically able to enter into the
philosophical argument that a person
like that my the way in which a person
like that's mind might work I was really
impressed so how'd you do that well look
at the heart of this great art the novel
we are talking about lies the human
capacity to identify with what we call
the other the other is the word we
invent for the academic word we invent
for people who are not like us and since
to be able to talk to be able to talk
about these people these people who are
not like us is the problem of last 20
years and we have invented a word for
this general concept and call it other
and there's so much academic stuff about
the other and while I strongly feel that
the the art of the novel is based on
this human sang that of the capacity and
it's also a limited capacity the
capacity to be able to identify with the
other that is people who are not like us
only human beings can do this it
requires imagination a sort of morality
a self-imposed agenda of understanding
is person who's like who's not like us
which is a rarity and once you begin to
do that then you also imply a frame a
frame of understanding you with that you
define a group because a groups are made
of people sometimes like us and
sometimes are not like us or once you
begin to identify yourself with people
who are not like you you begin to
enlarge your frame of mind you begin to
see things differently and it produces a
text which covers the ground bit in
between that is a so first of all if you
want to be a novelist the kind of novel
is like say post Tolstoy Dostoevsky
Thomas Mann the great masters of this
art then it that this in human capacity
these artists
have managed to develop this capacity
inherit I think I strongly believe that
inherent in all human beings in such
depth that not only we read the novels
but the nation's these novels turn out
to be text that the whole nation based
its communication in itself and so now
you're asking me how did you do that
well I don't know that the personal side
I don't want to explain of course I have
read a lot to understand the inner
workings of the political Islam it's
their radical but then there I should
also warn you that that that I have a
political Islamist in my part of the
world the person had so much affinities
with the 30 years ago in political
Marxist there is a continuity of
patterns of tov anti-western ISM all
parallelism and all sorts of theories I
conspiracy theories in place of logical
thinking and I especially nationalism
disguised as anti-imperialism and all
these patterns of thought are shared by
the marxists and Islamists in ways in
this some new collection there's a an
essay called are on my name is red and
many of you know my name is red i think
it was one of the most popular novels so
far and i love i have to say i love that
you apologize for the plot and for the
structure of the novel and to me this is
incredibly humble thing to do see he
says as i was finishing the book it
seemed to me that the mystery plot the
detective story was forced that my heart
wasn't in it but it was too late to make
changes I had worried that no one would
be interested in my lovely miniatures
unless I found some device to draw the
reader in so can you talk about well
first I know also from reading your
essay is that your first love was
panting and you painted I think from
when you were 7 221
t2 and you've written this also essay in
here about why you didn't become an
architect so I've to questions like why
why did you not think that paints the
interest in painting would hold the
weight and also why did you not stick
with painting why did pain why did you
become a writer as opposed to a painter
so I'm so much to say about this first
and that between the ages of seven and
22 I wanted to be a painter encouraged
by my family I'm coming from a family of
civil engineers and then since I was
even in the childhood at a bit of an
artsy boy that and everyone did the
black sheep of the family everyone said
this one will go to the same school with
his grandfather same school with his
father and uncles Istanbul Technical
University but this one will be
architect which is a bit of artsy
engineer that's what they thought of him
and then I drop out of school suddenly
yeah I can't explain that and begin
writing novels and stop painting and
then everyone asked me when I managed to
establish myself as a Turkish novelist
in my mid-30s ABM everyone began to ask
me why did you stop painting an
architecture studying architecture and
begin writing novels and whenever they
ask me I look at them as if they had all
the lights on my eyes and I'm a habit I
didn't have a one single answer because
perhaps and in fact I wrote my book
istanbul in ways to explain that it's
400 page book in the end if you read
that book you understand that I ok em
then him the second part of the question
was there is a continuously I think with
being an artist that those between 15
years when I in a teenage years that I
went when I had learned to that art be
quite self imposed discipline not only
that that you have to be alone in a room
that's that's my temperament I'm that
kind of person but then now as i get
older i return back to my childhood so
to speak now i'm also writing more about
in there in classic age they call them
sister rocks that now in fact at the
columbia now i'm teaching with unveils
professor andreas who isn't a course i'm
proud of he called in pictures and verbs
which is a sort of a survey of history
of humanity's influence of painting and
literature or in more general in human
thought and images and words in fact we
are coming everyone i hope the students
come to the realization that what is at
fault in the end when we entertain a
thought in our minds i do we pass
pictures there or do images there or do
we entertain words there and the answer
is both of course that verbs and
pictures in our minds work in such a way
that what we call idea and totes are
made up of a sort of a combination of
words and pictures and so I'm always
constantly now as I get older and now I
feel that I have to address what I what
had happened to me in my childhood why
it painted and and also there's also a
dramatic appoint in this in the sense
that my nation's history all the cheese
tray of Islamic nations are also
embedded heavily embedded with the idea
at that Quran or Islam more or less
prohibits images and painting that's
obvious while you on the other hand even
the Ottoman Sultans didn't care about
that that they had made paintings inside
the book inside the books and find
excuses to do so in itself an
interesting subject so forth and so on
it's really interesting because
increasingly with young artists they I
find that artists work now be so much
between forms they come in often two
schools of art wanting to manifest ideas
and then it's just the question of the
appropriate form or forms it's less a
genre based more about the thinking and
then what form will
suit the thought or the idea or the
concept of the mission or the project so
I think you might think that way future
you're going to see more maybe we see it
already with media that's okay but on
the other hand the cost of this is that
we the understanding of art and
literature in this manner I respect that
that is we have an idea we have a
sensibility we want to express ourselves
as artists and what venue what what r /
it may be literature it may be
architecture it may be painting and
other arts as all film other arts as
well I understand I I have sympathy for
this kind of representation of the
artist but that neglect the whole
classic of idea of class mention now my
response here is very conservative that
if you care if you say that well I like
arts but first we have to learn the
craft the hand should know it before the
mind and especially a painting the class
even all the glories of Renaissance is a
deer is due to that is that
craftsmanship first the hand and the
patron who tells you just to here is
your money do my portrait okay and then
we have five years five hundred years
later invented the uniqueness of these
artists that that we have now represent
them in our minds eye as people who are
expressing themselves while actually
they were more substance less
self-centered than we now think trying
to understand arts as a sort a sort of
an self-expression is something I
respect but that neglects the fact that
that there should be a lot of very
classical very traditional craftsmanship
education that I think although a person
may now that we have conceptual arts
maybe we can more popularly known or all
these things and objects even
this can be we can put in a frame and
show it as an art and I don't have to do
together is not even a friend yeah just
yet okay now we think that that anyone
can be an artist in but if anyone can be
an artist in if that person executed
conceptual art but what about the art
that requires the hand they cover the
pigments the all sorts of information
about the stuff and I care about that
and perhaps because I long paying
attention to medieval post Medieval
Renaissance arts so it is I think a bit
if we can think of any person who wants
to express his himself whether he or she
should study painting or literature or
he where he or she can do all but then
there are limits to human time and
acquiring craftsmanship be really
interesting to have this conversation
with the students at the school of the
art all come be okay you're on my list
you actually unnatural your boss and
you're actually working you're actually
on my faculty yeah that's why do you
talk here it's a great debate in the
schools of art about Milan with this too
much but there's a great debate in
schools of art about whether or not all
artists would ever form they're going to
work in need to learn I know yeah this
is a big debate because people will say
well filmmakers do filmmakers really
need to draw and then as a whole school
of thought that says yes absolutely
everyone needs to draw so that we can
have this conversation with your
students okay I I wanted to back to your
writing and Istanbul which i read with
such delight because other than portrait
of the artist Ulysses you know this
notion of how someone becomes a writer
the book is really for me how an
imagination is challenged for a whole
childhood and at the very end declares
itself this imagination will be a writer
and it's a wonderful kind of pristine
moment where you sort of the book starts
the book ends where it actually begins
which is you as as writer so I guess I
wanted to ask
what what did you learn writing that
book well in fact my anxiety was not
learning something above putting
together all my memories in a shape and
yes I learned something from during the
writing of the book we live so much we
remember so much and writing
autobiography is deleting or editing out
ninety-five percent of your life and
it's such a painful process that I have
so many wonderful anecdotes of say my
primary school which I shared with
everyone but if I write all of them then
you know if I have I have to cover till
the age of 22 I have to write another
ten volumes this is amazing to me
because it is so precise your memory is
so precise that there's so much in it
and you think there's much more that you
have seventy-five percent more yes of
course that's that's amazing I think the
older remember like that yeah I don't
think so no really it's so it's so
precise in particular your your memory
of every event of you it seems to me
every event of your childhood you
remember like a like a camera but I
don't think everyone has those that I
don't know I also it's it's some part of
it like this is that we don't remember
me don't you remember if you're alone on
a girl and if you are writing that book
then you would remember to then if you
have also the education and the high
standard of now I have to be humble here
of good literature then not only you
remember then you also pay attention to
remember it clearly so that words come
out that that literature is also about
convincing people it's not only your
personal self expression then then you
have to remember and you have to also
know that you remember the thing that
they will also remember once you begin
go so deep and go introverted and begin
a in fact experiencing in with your
writing and with yourself then you
understand that aren't you dear word by
word not only remembering your char
you are remembering the childhood of
humanity you also as you write
understand that all human beings are
alike that you are sure that if you put
that detail there that they will all
understand because it's so unique it may
be unique to you but it's so original
because you have lived it and they will
understand and they understand I cried
through your essay about your father and
the Nobel speech my father's suitcase
which some of you may have already seen
so also in the book it's such a
beautiful essay in such a tribute to
father and I was so interested in your
either so much I could say about this
and so much I think you'll say about
this but two things that his temperament
was such that you say he was too
comfortable in his skin to assured about
the future ever to be gripped by the
essential passions of literary
creativity and you say he believed that
life is not something to be earned but
to be enjoyed and so in and this is sort
of your explanation in some way I think
why he would not have pursued the kind
of literary career that you pursued even
though he wrote and then the other piece
of this is this wonderful notion that we
don't really want to know the interior
lives of our parents that our own
narcissism precludes are wanting to
understand them other than as our
parents so I would like you to just talk
about your father okay first that thing
that the big to the people who don't
know about these essays that we have to
give information that my father's father
was a very rich man and that made life
easier America easier for him then also
he is coming from a secular westernized
family who had enjoyed the first two or
three decades of the modern Turkish
camel attitudes modern Turkish Republic
that they were heavily circular heavily
westernized or aspired to Western to be
westernized and they strongly believed
in Turkish nationalism and Turkish
Occidental ism
ization which Masconomet reduce project
and that and that made them identify
with west and also identify with it that
the way it to see represent Occidental
ization a sort of see if it is a road
towards road towards civilization that
that said and now that my father at my
father being the son of a very rich
family did I strongly felt did not want
to end you or live through the hardship
of a literary life in a country and say
in mid 650s late 40s 60s a literal life
would be a very tough life than that
that they would make fun of you that
they would you would never make money
with then get that he would be
considered a rich man that would be
considered a rich man's fancy to be a
writer and then also a the freedom was
so narrow that oh of course he would be
in trouble that he didn't want that that
that is understandable there on the
other hand he was an intelligent person
who enjoyed books and inspired to write
that kind that sort of stuff but then
where to publish how to publish what to
do does he want to go radicalize it he
would also behind his back make it he he
also had literally friends but then he
that stayed with me he would also behind
their back you know but in a charming
manner mocked them for only addressing
the Turkish audience Turkish leadership
that he he implied and that I have
learned even in my in my childhood that
an author should address not the
national concerns but all humanity and
would talk about discount Paris all the
time because when he was bored because
he used to come here and go to hotel
rooms and fill notes books pages and
pages of notebooks which he gave me
before he died when he sends that
unfortunately death the end is coming
and that and those moments were so
touching because then his generation and
my father lost all my grandfather's
money and then I was unfair
uncomfortable lacked self says I would
say confidence about money my father had
I was nervous and he was obviously
saying well you guys meaning me and my
brother he has to work hard I was
privileged but then there's no money
left children too bad but it isn't such
a graceful nice manner that you like the
man for even saying that and so I both
and because of him because he had such a
immense good library and cared about all
these jean-paul Sartre and coming
instead of partials and saints in Turkey
that let left and and gave me this
burden of the library and these were the
guys that I have to imitate or be like
that I should take it as examples the
modern light writer as a secular saying
this was the person I wanted to be but
what my father suggested I should be
with his library with his regrets and
charming anecdote and so when he came to
me with his suit is fulfilled with his
notebooks which he were not even sure
about the quality of their quality that
was a touching moment and I thought now
that I haven't lived as pleasurably as
Jair as in a neck air i would say
comfortably as he was and perhaps i'm
going to lead even much more partial x
in future at least this is a moment and
he was much much such a good looking
person that's also something that i
should know their old wanna bring that
up and and so this was a little bit of
that moment of a child's revenge or
about the father now that you may be
surprised that i'm talking about revenge
father this but then i think all these
urges about talking about life in this
manner but you you write so wonderfully
about his accepting pneus of
that he was never an authoritarian
father he was never obstructed you
always supported you this is sort of
wonder this is the advice that I can
give to all my father's and friends all
the fathers and friends and all the
parents that even the most stupid thing
that I would do in life you know putting
this or throwing this year and say oh
this is genius and not because he really
believed that I also sometimes thought
because he believed in himself so much
that only genius son can do nothing but
that that gave me the self-confidence
that I liked can you talk about you I
mean you've written so much about this
notion of the center in the periphery
and east and west and in and in so many
essays now I think you even move beyond
all of it you just say basically I don't
even want to go there anymore but but
you talk about writers who were network
physically on what the so-called
periphery like board hiss or but you but
but actually we're always central in
terms of the contribution and I would
add to that people like netted or Garcia
Marquez in the same way can you talk a
little bit about that yes of course
that's being I live practically all my
life in Istanbul except these last week
23 years and then that is also heavily
embedded in the idea that as we were
living especially in 1950s 60s 70s we
are living in the provinces the center
of the world is someplace else the
history and the major decisions about
our lives be it historical we have about
fashion clothes literature films aren't
anything everything are being made in
someplace else in west CO and also is
since we are identifying with the
project of westernization is even more
painful we believe in them but we are
not them we are following that but we
are not part of it that gives you a
sense of heavy sense of of living in the
provinces living on the sides not at the
center I it was VS Naipaul who use this
world where more than once and suggested
which I like I may not be a I may not
agree with
is political remarks but Nigel is a good
observer of what is academically called
post-colonial situation that cannot be
that's wrong in a flying in Turkey
because turkey was never at Western
colony was never be Turks are never
victims of cold imperialism so forth and
so on and that makes the Turkish
situation in ways you need but then
being it being at the map on the margins
not living in the center inspiring to go
to Center these are subjects I like and
then cultural consequences of this kind
of logic or in fact I would call this
not logic but a sentiment is is an
impact is a important part of my work I
can illustrate this very simple example
that when my first book books were
reviewed in a very positive way in turn
by international press by American press
when i wrote a day they like say a love
scene i had the sense that if pushed
Marcel posts wrote about love they would
say this is the general universal on if
I wrote about love and they liked it
this is only loyal I all my life I
fought against it and I think I think
humanities arts is in fact there is a
clash of something in world and that is
that to impose your story to others to
make others accept your story and not to
pigeonhole you to an ethnic or national
identity but accept your humanity as a
part of a whole humanity accept your
your story as humankind story not your
ethnic and national story we're going to
run out of time so I want to ask two
things that I want to make sure we talk
about and it has to do with the issue of
freedom of expression and we talked a
little bit about it earlier but there is
always this notion when artists and
writers speak out or political people
speak out that somehow in that speaking
out in that attempt to expose the lies
the country or the contradictions of
one's own society
you're being anti-american anti Turkish
when in fact when you're doing it you
feel one feels that you're being the
most patriotic and I remember so much
you know picket lines in the 60s in
America and people yelling you know go
back to Russia I know I thought go back
to Russia no don't come from Russia I
come from this country and I'm trying to
make a statement about this country and
anti-war demonstrations and certainly
this has been true in the United States
with the war in Iraq and then you talk I
think quite elegantly about the notion
of these are my words but the novelist's
desire ability compulsion and obligation
to record and these are your words the
secret shames of his or her society even
though others want to keep them hidden
and need to keep them hidden and feel
betrayed when they are made visible so
I've seen this in also in south africa
and i was talking to early about jam
could see and his novel disgrace and
when that novel came out the way the anc
responded to it which was very negative
even though it was an accurate
representation a part of the reality not
the whole reality but part of the
reality of South Africa and I know that
it was very painful for him and you've
lived with the same kind of
contradictions first a political
hardship I would say has taught me not
to pay attention to it mmm rhetorical
figures or retro reticle maneuvering of
say political enemies if you insult your
they say if they insult something you
shouldn't go back and say you know
that's not the fact it's a you should
not pay much attention to that's what I
think too to the what they say about you
so harm you you one should one's mine
should not be concerned about what say a
ultra right winger what lines and ultra
right winger says about me in turkey or
in fact also there are people want to
block Turkey and they also pressure so
that I borrow your hand in a semi
repressed society say
a cutsy South Africa or any other once
you make talk about things that the
establishment does don't want you to
talk about then they have that's why
they are establishment anyway they have
the power to misrepresent you and you
cannot fight that even if you fight back
it's so hard to convince the majority of
the people that this is not true it's
inevitable you call them establishment
because yes they have the media they
have the army they have whatever they
have that this is not only in Turkey
every place that once in fact that's the
definition of being critical being
critical is to say something to the
establishment and to say something
against the media and it has cost my
point here is that I was not after that
right and I was not I did not have a
heavy political agenda most of the time
and this is also be I don't have a
political agenda just I just get angry I
have a 1 more comment they they asked 50
questions and eight months stage i said
i want to say the truth and then
sometimes the scituate politics
situation is so repressive and so close
that that little thing that you say are
is enlarged and large and large and they
give it back to you either you have to
take a step back or wait to his pass
either way that's that all my political
my situations that I found myself into
it fell on my lap rather than all I said
oh here is a new political agenda or
enemy I never thought of that way I
really strongly see myself as a person
who is writing in a solitary all all the
time and in my youth I meant to
political meetings and I was in the
first three minutes board so much that i
would go to towards the other end and
live the life like that I knew I know
that politics is a matter of community
having friends back-slapping joining
especially when a part of the world
drinking together living together
thinking
together while on the other an art of
the novel implies that you'll be another
person that you don't join the community
so cheaply and willingly we're good
about that time so I want to ask you
this one thing which is that you say
that in the implied author that since
all of these all of the work that you've
done has become so politicized and that
you've been thrust into the public arena
even though you'd rather stay in your
room and write and lock yourself away
but that in fact it's helps you to grow
up you say and to give up a certain
childishness so do on top of that yeah
but then i but then that's not you yeah
these are mine boards but then I'm not
happy growing up oh that I make it
pretty clear in that I say that that I
think in a creative thinking requires a
sort of irresponsibility that that
seriousness and responsibility that the
society demands that you impose on
yourself and others it vanishes once you
find yourself in a political situation
and honor and creativity requires a sort
of a freedom of a child who thinks
without a who does not consider the
political consequence or any other
consequence of his playfulness and in
fact new ideas come to us when we pay
attention to this and put that in fact
playfulness and child put a childish
pneus on a pedestal and then that is
contradictory with politics I think we
have to move to questions even though i
have i have many okay here we go
okay all right okay you may skip that I
may skip the first one just cuz I don't
quite understand it who are you readers
in Turkey oh okay that is a very popular
question that everyone asks both in
Turkey and outside of Turkey and I think
my teachers in Turkey my are this my
answer will be the same all over the
world my readers and our insert in
Turkey and also out of Turkey are always
the same that that of woman who like who
like to read novels students who like to
read novels and coat intellectuals who
are also to catch up the scene who is
writing what also people who read novels
but not everyone that that it's a most
of a that I sometimes joke in Turkey
maybe less true outside of turkey is
that I that ninety-five percent of men
are over 35 don't read novels in my part
of the world but it's also true in other
places as well at that and that's
because of and I have seen so many
resentful at it you'd say well I could
have written novels to you know but
they're so you know so so so many things
to do in life you know my or Oh mr.
Pamuk you know I don't like I don't like
your political comments but I respect
you're a serious writer can you can you
autograph this book for my wife of
course and but then students or people
who care about creativity and different
ideas about the representing of the
nation of the problems of nation all the
things that a good intellectual students
that are that makes a good intellectual
student enthusiastic all the all these
people read my novels but and also again
women readers with who also you know
perhaps a la Madame Bovary but that
but then yeah that's that's the same
it's not a Turkish situation it said
it's a global situation could you
comment on the geographic distribution
of the novel are their literary coaches
without novels and if so why wow it is
positionally Franco Mariotti who was a
Columbia professor now in Stanford
unfortunately he wrote about
geographical origins and extensively
about the geographical mapping of the
art of the novel and paid so much
attention to this geography I think
sometimes he loses the point but now
that as I just said before the art of
the novel is a global art now there is
no no not that anyone who reads books in
translation in a corner of the world
which is not perhaps similar to ours and
what is similar to ours anyway and may
want and once to write novels it is a
global art in some corners problems are
different the form is pulled to this
direction in some corners the leadership
is not ready the artist this or this or
because of this or that perhaps fails in
some corners they're interesting things
are being made or like in France here
that that the glories had been lived a
hundred years ago or up to fifty years
ago and because because of this or
because of that there that they are not
using this great gadget they have
invented as fruitful as the others so it
there is not a one single we cannot make
it a generalization about the art of the
novel except that it is definitely a
global art and then if in fact we
realize the unity of humanity and worlds
soothed by the fact that everyone wants
to write novels how does one reconcile
understanding the point of view of
someone else the quote other with
keeping faith in the validity of one's
own personal beliefs in other words if
you gain an understanding of your
opponent's perspective how do you
continue to support your own okay this
is a very
Carty and Cartesian representation of
human minds which is also a that
Cartesian understanding of human mind is
also a passing thing that it means that
we have our minds are considered in such
a way that we can only entertain one
single tote and it should be dominant it
has cartesian rationality which we have
seen in Turkey to has also
authoritarianism TSA's that if he
represent in our minds eye that human
beings our mind should be consistent
about the thoughts that we entertain
then we neglect so many parts of our
mental energy while on the other hand I
strongly believe that we may have a
Cartesian Center on one part then other
thoughts that contradicted other
sensibilities that also thoughts are not
again are not only verbs we have also in
pictorial sensations desires which is
not a design is not a tote we may have a
tone and we may have a contradictory
desire as Bible says and so that that
the fact that we should make everything
in our minds uniform is maybe a good
idea for an authoritarian or a very code
more modern vision of society but it's
not the fact that in fact the beauty of
the human mind that we have so many
self-contradictory sentiments towards
designs visions pictures verbs in our
minds the interesting thing about
writing novels is that all these
mechanisms once you begin to write a
novel is working galloping so to speak
in fully and then execution and writing
of a novel is putting them in shape that
one part of our mind things one thing or
wishes something than the other part
contradicts and Dostoyevsky this work is
a good testimony ponen you now have a
global audience but you also carry in
your books your cultural national
identity the sociological development of
your country Turkey currently you spend
more and more time outside
Turkey how will this impact your next
novel since I plan my books ahead and
since I as a as I get older I'm writing
books that I've been thinking about last
ten years five years I'm finishing a
book that I've been thinking about to
last ten years and so I haven't felt the
consequences of being outside of the
last two years again that this may
happen but then I some I have so many
projects that i strongly think that that
it will take so much time to exhaust
them write them for so for the time
being a living outside half my a half of
my time living outside of Turkey did not
hurt my writing so to speak but then
hurting my writing is in fact being
disloyal to my spirit then if say in 10
years I write about these experiences I
would write them in a authentic way in a
heartfelt way if I ever do
whoa these are long okay okay you
mentioned the impact of the novel and
its impact on political debate and
national identity how do you reconcile
this with declining reading rates are
the literary class is the literary class
simply discussing amongst itself while
the rest of the world moves on without
paying any mind I suspect this is
written by a man this question that is
why do you say because this is typical
typical maybe I'm wrong and excuse me a
typical of the dismissive attitude
towards the art of the novel as a is
something that intellectuals in the
ivory tower is using and lesser and less
people are reading these things and it's
also address writing novels is only now
was only address the intellectuals
things that my mummy for me 35 years ago
do we want me to answer that is that the
answer moving right along do you ever
have doubts about the practical value of
political expression to art problem do
you ever have doubts about the practical
value of political expression through
art has this value change through
history is the practical value of art
less potent in current times and how do
you process the potential conflicts
between practicality and arts ok it's a
very philosophical question but actually
it's a simple question put in philosophy
cool terms I think you're gonna be a
fantastic really thank you I've born she
beautiful the question is more more
simply do you believe that if you put
little politics in your books it will be
practical that is people will be
affected in fact that was well as I
infer to my problem and I don't live in
has a good thing that we should use in
literature perhaps because as in early
1970s in Turkey when I was paying so
much attention for previous generation
of Turkish writers some of which were
really heavily talented but destroyed or
wasted their talents to serve their
country to serve the nation with with
their moral agenda political agenda and
there of course there are there is a
practical side to it let's think let's
think about the place of grapes of wrath
which is a politically very politically
motivated book by John Steinbeck some
now say that it was not politically good
representation of the situation or
whatever that book greats of fred has
such a great impact on in american
history and of course there are so many
others in history but then let's not let
us not be deceived by that political
code practicality sometimes practicality
is horrible there is no political result
and the book is bad what about that and
so politics literature is again like a
shot pistol shot in a concert you may
achieve some I would say good results
and you may achieve come up with nothing
also it is related to your temperament
do you want them do you want to do want
to book to write books like that I
remember when I was trying to establish
myself using this example of John
Steinbeck who influenced so many Turkish
writers are not only for many Turkish
writers so many I would say to third
world writers by his strong political
convictions by his by his also he also
managed to keep his integrity and his
his style his uniqueness and he wasn't
such an unhappy influence on Turkish
writers even the best one that to be
provocative in my early late twenties
and early thirties I would say I would
never
we adjourn steinbeck I would see you I
said I said this he was heavily
translated so many translations in
Turkey to make a comment that
unfortunately in the end I found myself
in politics but but that's not my agenda
I want to be proved I want to be someone
like no bucko Cruz or money that's what
I thought we're gonna I have these
little cards that flash to tell me I'm
supposed to stop now so I would like you
to read something just just okay just
this I marked it for you and if you
could just read that that would be our
conclusion I think you should have the
voice as the writer okay this is from
from light from my this book from my
father suitcase and an article in this
is also my Nobel Prize acceptance sage
the speech and the title is the speech
title is yes my father suitcase and it's
the ending of it in that speech perhaps
I want to address more or less most
essential questions that the readers
asked to read write readers asked to
writers and of course not all of them
but the ones I I felt most relevant and
most interesting and most
straightforward and honest and I try to
give the most again straightforward and
honest answer as you know the question
we writers are asked most often the
favorite question is why do you write
here's an answer i right because i had i
have an innate need to write I write
because I can to normal work like other
people I write because i want to read
books like the ones I write I write
because I am angry at all of you angry
at everyone I write because I love
sitting in a room all day writing I
write because I can only partake in real
life by changing it i right because I
want others all of us the whole world to
know what sort of life we lived and
continue to live in Istanbul in Turkey I
right because I love the smell of paper
and an inch I write because I believe in
literature in
art of the novel more than I believe in
anything else I write because it's a
habit a passion i right because I'm
afraid of being forgotten I write
because i like the glory and interest
that writing brings i right to be alone
perhaps I write because I hope to
understand why I am so very very angry
at all of you so very very angry at
everyone i right because I like to be
read i right because once i have begun a
novel and as a page I want to finish it
I write because everyone expects me to
write I write because i have a childish
leaf in the immortality of libraries and
in the way my books sit on the shelf I
write because it is exciting to turn all
of life's beauties and riches into worms
i right not to tell a story but to
compose a story I write because I wish
to escape from the foreboding that there
is a place I must go but just as in a
dream I can't quite get there I write
because I have never managed to be happy
i right to be happy thank you